what or who  within that sort of idea is tom bombadil  yeah  so tom bombadil is a fascinating  question and there are lots of different  ways to answer this question but he  basically it seems like he has to be uh  in that same kind of category of  creature right um  and uh even when elrond in the book  elrond talks about it right um you know  they at the council of elrond they  debate the question um because you know  it comes up briefly you may remember  they're like hey tom momma don't like  he he didn't even like he didn't even  turn invisible when he put the ring on  like he doesn't seem to be bothered by  the ring at all maybe we should just  bring the ring back to him and let him  keep it and then it'd be safe right um  and elrond is like no you know ellen and  gandalf both say look if sauron were to  come himself right and try to take the  ring away from tom bombadil could tom  bombadil  fight off sally  [Music]  the baby you're my  [Music]